こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
またちょっとごめんね気になる記事を見て
思ったことがあったので動画にしますもう
こういうのはね目に入ってしまうとね
やっぱり気になってしまいますそして見
ないようにしてるんですけども見ないよう
にしたものを見てしまった時のそのなんか
あー見ちまったなっていうこのショック感
本人はこういう気持ちなんだなっていうの
をぜひ動画で伝えたいと思って動画を撮っ
ております皆さんはなんかネットとか
SNSでYouTuberのランキングと
かって見たことありますか結構あるんです
よなんか
2023年の8月のランキングとかその次
の月には9月のランキング長いスパンで見
て2023年の上半期のランキングとか
それ絶対後半もやるよねみたいなそういう
ねYouTuberのランキングみたいな
やつをですねその独自でやっている会社と
かニュースサイトとかがありまして僕基本
的にそういうのあんまり見ないようにし
てるんですよなぜなら
ランク外だと悲しいからもちろんランク台
に入ってることもよくあるんですけれども
それでもなんかこうさ例えば3位だったの
に次の次に用意になってたとか4位だった
のに次の月に8位になってたとかランク
インしてたとしても悲しい気持ちになる
こともあるので僕そういう
YouTuberランキングとか極力見
ないようにしてるんですけれども
どぎついのがこれどぎついのが目に留まっ
てしまいました今回はじめしゃちょーの目
に留まってしまったランキングなんとね
LINEで載ってたのよもう
避けようがない避けようがないよ自分で
ランキング見ないようにこう
TwitterとかXだった自分で
ランキング見ないようにSNSこう
やりくりしてたんですけれどももう
LINEとかさその日常で使う何気なく
見るこのニュースのところにパッと見てさ
それもご覧くださいこちらなんか好きな
YouTuberとかそういうランキング
じゃなくて気になっちゃうんですよ昔好き
だったYouTuberランキング2位
水溜りボンド1位は
見ちゃういやそれは見るやろもう
YouTube11年目よこれだけに長く
やってたらやっぱその何だろう昔好きだっ
たYouTuberランキングとか入っ
てるのかなとか思っちゃったり昔好きだっ
たってこと今は好きじゃないってことどう
いう心の動きでそうなっちゃったのみたい
なこういう記事が出てて
プラスのランキングだけじゃなくて世の中
にはねこういう昔好きだったと
嫌いなYouTuberとかそういう
プレイヤーがね気にしちゃうような
ランキングを世にはあるわけですよで俺
恐る恐るこれ見たのよ
はいもう水溜りも残りどう思っているん
だろうなとみかんだ好きだったんだってお
疲れニュースですね視聴者との距離が近く
誰でも気軽に始められる動画投稿サイト
YouTube最近では小中学生が成田
職業に選ばれるほど影響力の大きい
YouTuberたちですが
競争や浮き沈みは激しいのが現実間違い
ないその通りなのよいろんな
YouTuberいますからね最近とか
ちょんまげ小僧人気すぎだろ次々に新しい
動画や人気YouTuberが誕生し話題
となっていますそうねでえっとこのオール
アバウトさんの編集部は7月の13から
23日7月ですね最近だね全国の人を対象
にYouTuberに関するアンケート
調査を実施しました今回はその中から昔
好きだったYouTuberランキングを
紹介しますということですね
あーまずはいいね水溜りボンド
富
[音楽]
田佐藤マイケル」って言うんだそうね彼ら
ももうずっと長いことやってますからね
まあ長くやってくるとねやっぱその好き
だったとか今見てない人も出ると思います
これ昔好きだったってことは最近の
YouTuberは乗ってないんですよだ
から多分歴の長いYouTuberが乗っ
てるんだろうなと思ってちょっと一言じゃ
ないなってなってきて俺ひょっとしたら
これあるのかなとかランクインしてたら
どうしようと思ってちょっとすごい気に
なっできたんですよ水溜りボンドを選んだ
理由とかも書かれてるんですよ
昔は好きで見ていたけれど興味の対象が
変わったので見なくなった
静岡県20代女性俺も静岡に住んでるんだ
けど知ってる人かな
人の人の興味って変わりますからねでも
興味の対象が変わったので見なくなっ
たってちょっと
悲しいなくだらないことを本気でやって
いる感じが好きだったから今も本気でやっ
てるよあいつらはそんなこと言うなよ
まあ個人の見解か個人の意見だったらまあ
仕方ないなドッキリなどの企画が面白かっ
たから今もたまに見ているが昔ほどでは
ないなるほどねまあまあまあまあそもそも
昔と比べてYouTubeチャンネル増え
ましたからねどんだけYouTuber
いるのっていうもうテレビで例えると選ぶ
チャンネルがめちゃくちゃ増えちゃって
ますからね今極端なこと言うと昔はなんか
テレビ番組12チャンネルしか
YouTubeなかったのに今もう
5000チャンネルありますよみたいな
それはやっぱ見たいものが変わって気も
すると思いますよはい
という感じでまあ水溜りボンドが2位に
ランクインしたということで次第1位
本当に怖い
行きます見ますね
傷つく覚悟できてます俺じゃないことを
願う行きます
俺だ
[音楽]
皆さんどうも
昔好きだったYouTuberランキング
1位はじめしゃちょーです
[音楽]
か
[拍手]
楽しい
嫌な思いさせて楽しいですか
こんなランキング見て
嬉しいと思いますか
ふと見てみましょう1位は日本を代表する
人気YouTuberの人にはじめしゃ
ちょーさんでした
甘いマスクと甘い
言い過ぎだよ
子供心を忘れない挑戦で子供から大人まで
楽しめる動画で知られています3弦の豪邸
を購入したことでも話題になりました今
4億円です
この先が怖いんだよな何書かれてるん
だろうなマジで怖い回答ありますね回答で
は
昔見ていたが最近は見なくなった千葉県
30代女性
ちょっとお姉さんの方
昔見てたのかな
[音楽]
いや普通に悲しいですよ
昔は見ていたが最近は見なくなったって
もうちょい理由まで教えて言うまで教え
たら前書するからできるところは
やっぱ前処しないわ好き勝手やらせて
もらうわ
自分のチャンネルの
趣旨変えるとこだったよあくまで僕は自分
のしたいことやるっていうチャンネルで
ずっとやっているのでまあこういう人も
言っても仕方ないYouTube見始めた
頃は誰を見ていいかわからずはじめしゃ
ちょーのゲーム動画を見てたゲーム動画見
てた人なのね40代の女性ありがとう
ございますなるほどねーそっかーなるほど
ねー
[音楽]
甘いマスクかいい記事書きますね
まあ気になる
題材ではあると思いますよ昔好きだった
YouTuber
逆に1位と2位ないんかなおちょっと
サイトに飛ぶとランキング10位まで出て
ますねちょっと見ましょうかどいつキーが
SKY東海オンエアが8あ東海も入ってる
んだね8位
タケヤキ賞竹脇さんてんちむさん
4位から1位ヒカルさん
フィッシャーズこの勢いだと多分3位は
HIKAKINさんそうだよねそうなっ
ちゃうよねやっぱ昔からやってる人がこう
いうのにランクインするんでしょうね
[音楽]
違う俺か
好きだったYouTuberね
まあまあなんか僕もね昔はその青年な感じ
出てたと思うんですよなんか身近に感じる
お兄さんみたいなねあの20歳から25歳
ぐらいまではそのやっぱ若さとかもあるし
その発言のなんかあどけなさとかその少年
感とかなんかそういうなんだろう今とは
またねちょっと雰囲気が違う
初めて社長としてねみんなに見られてた気
もするんですよそれもあるしそもそも
さっきも言いましたけどYouTube
自体がユーチューバー自体がそんな流行っ
てなかったからまだ出始めの時期だった
からYouTuberといえばヒカキン
はじめしゃちょーみたいな感じだった時も
あります昔はそん中でもう最近はね
YouTuberっていうのがすごい人気
になってきてグループ系YouTuber
がたくさん出てきてこういろんな人が
いろんなYouTubeを楽しめるように
なったもうジャンルもね色々ありますよ
もうゲーム実況ですごい強い人もいるし
気まぐれクックさんみたいにも料理で強い
人もいるし筋トレ動画でもすごい人気です
ジャンルがね無限に広がり続けてて
それはねずっとはじめ社長だけ好きな
チャンネルということもないと思うので
いたって自然な流れかなとは思いますはい
悲しいですけれども
昔好きだったと言われるのは
今は好きじゃないってまあでもはじめしゃ
ちょーも歳をとりますからスタイルも
変わってきます動画な感じも変わります誰
が昔の
少年感があったはじめしゃちょーが4件の
うちに住むと思ったでしょうか誰も思わ
ない人ってね変わる生き物なんですよ俺
だって言いますよ昔は好きだった人とか昔
は好きだったアイドルとか昔は好きだった
歌手昔は好きだった芸能人こじはるさんは
今も好きです人の思考が好きな物って
ついに変わり続けるのでこれはまあ自然な
流れだと思いますただ1位は悲しいこの
事実だけはここで伝えておきます
[音楽]
昔から見てる人今も見てよ
昔と比べて色々増えたよなんかインスタ
すごい人気だTwitterはxになる
tiktok大人気YouTubeを立て
動画昔と比べて色んなことが変わりました
けど僕が動画を出すという声は変わって
ません僕は変わりましたけども皆さんも
変わりましたよね
変わらないものなんてないんですただ僕は
動画を出すはじめ社長というものだけは
変わらず今も生きています
[音楽]
昔好きだった人
よかったらもう一度見てください自分のし
たいことを動画に出すというこのスタンス
は変わらずに今もやっています
ちょっと大人になりましたけどはじめしゃ
ちょー生きてますはいなんかねこういう
ランキングねちょっと
悲しいですね昔は好きだったのこの
烙印を押されたわけですから僕が今
何だろうなぁダメなのかな
はじめ社長終わりか
もう運ん
だって思いましたがこれ別のランキングが
あるんですよこれちょっと見てみましょう
か好きなYouTuberランキング2位
はじめしたでしょ2段階
[音楽]
僕に
えみんな僕に好きだったYouTuber
ランキング1位だけども好きな
YouTubeにどっち
どっちオワコンなのか今の人気なのか
どういうことなんでしょう見てみましょう
か好きなYouTubeランキングに
はじめしゃちょー1位は2023年最新
調査これも7月の末に行われている最新の
調査ですね同じようにアンケートを取った
やつでですね私はじめ社長2位ですやっ
たーいはやった
終わってなかった
いやどっちこれマジで何なんだろうなぁ
ちょっと
読もうかにはじめしゃちょーにランクイン
したのはYouTuberマネジメント
事務所ウームの所属のはじめしゃちょー
はじめしゃちょーでした大学の同級生と
結成したはじめ看板に動画投稿を開始その
後個人チャンネルを開設し名前も現在の
はじめしゃちょーとなりましたコメント見
てみます
企画が面白いから東京都20代女性
ありがとう大変親しみを感じるからです
えー40代男性マジ
見ていると楽しくて元気になれる人柄が
良さそう分かってる
ありがとうございます新潟の40代の女性
の方ありがとうございますそうなんですよ
親しみがあるんですよそうなんですよ
自分でそうなんですよ言っちゃダメです
けどもいや嬉しいわ好きなYouTube
嬉しいもう俺どっちなんだろう好きだった
YouTuber好きなYoutuber
両方ランクインしてるんですよその上位に
わけわかんないんですよもう一応1位見
ます1位はねもうこれわかる
HIKAKINさんなんですよほらすぐ
わかったHIKAKINさんはもう間違い
ないですね
ラブ何なんだろうな
めちゃくちゃ長いじゃないですかだから
好きだったっていう人も多いのわかるん
ですけども好きなYouTuberにも
ランクインしてるって事は
どっち
これは
喜んでいいんでしょうか昔も人気だったし
今も人気ですっていうことで大丈夫ですか
[音楽]
よかった
よかった全然じゃあよかったですなんか
時々ニュースとかで言われるんですよその
はじめしゃちょーオワコンみたいなの
お前誰だよ気遣いたやつ誰だよなんか
終わって難しい言葉ですけどもまあ少なく
てもコンテンツ的に終わってるとニュース
にも乗らないよねニュースに載ってる時点
で
終わってないと思うんですよ僕に限らず
全てのコンテンツを発信してる人って
ニュースとかそういうのに載ってる時点で
コンテンツ的に終わってないんですよなぜ
なら引きがあるから水溜りボンドとか俺と
か2位だったけどこうやって名前が挙がっ
てる人で終わってないし本当に終わってる
コンテンツだったらそもそもこういう記事
にすらならないと思いますなのでこうやっ
てねありがたいことによくも悪くも
ニュースとかに
働いてる時は
終わってないなと思っていいのかなと
はじめしゃちょーは思ってますだからあの
みんな良かったら反論しといてもし今後ね
やっぱ浮き沈みあるよ再生回数とか沈ん
でる時にオワコンとかいうニュースとか
記事とかあったら記事になってる時点で
オワコンじゃない
証明終了QEDそれってあの書いてくれる
とすごい助かりますマジで誰々オワコン系
YouTubeを書いてる時点でもう破綻
してるんですよ意味が話題にならないこと
が本当のオワコンだと思いますはじめしゃ
ちょーは昔は好きだった今日今も好きよっ
ていう人もたくさんいるということなんだ
と思ってますそうだととても嬉しいです
最近のYouTuberで次世代
YouTuberと
旧世代YouTuberっていう言葉よく
使われると思うんですけどやっぱり僕は歴
が長いので旧世代YouTuberに位置
するんですよ
[音楽]
旧世代ね
そうか
古いか
まぁ歴が長いからそう思われても仕方ない
ですけどもあの一応現役でやってますから
現役でやってますから9世代って言われる
とちょっとね古く感じるのでちょっと嫌
ですちょっと嫌だけどまぁ新世代
YouTuberがいるから
昔からやってる人が旧世代と呼ばれるのは
仕方ないと思うけど
旧時代YouTuberと言われる人たち
もみんな今も現役でバリバリに動画出し
てる人たくさんいるのでなんかちょっとね
9って呼ばれるのは
違和感というか
旧世代YouTuberというより現在
進行形YouTuberっていう感じだと
嬉しいかな
悪く言うと生きた化石生きた化石系
YouTuberと呼んでくれるといや
それもやだなそもそも世代で分けるべき
じゃないと思ったよな同じ世代に生きてる
わけだしYouTubeの時代が100年
とか続いてよHIKAKINさんとか僕と
かフィッシャーズが年をとっておじい
ちゃんになってYouTube引退した頃
に
旧世代YouTuberって言ってくれる
くらいが
いいんじゃないのかなとも思います
長いスパンのYouTubeを見るとね
いつまでYouTubeの人気が続くか
分かりませんがさあそんな中ですね色んな
記事まだあるんですよこれ面白いと思い
ましたイケメンだと思うYouTuber
ランキングにヒカルを抑えた1位は
誰だろう失礼しますこれも2023年の
最新調査だうわぁ10位からありますね見
ていきましょう
徹也
哲也
ミッキー君
ヒューが
涼君で8位なのもっと親分HIKAKIN
さん
[音楽]
かっこいい
黄色い広告やだな
ヤマト4位
ヤマトで4位なの
竹脇君かっこいいもんな
俺いなくね
何がヒカルさん
1位が
やった嬉しい
[音楽]
ちょっと皆さんの意見見てみましょうか高
身長だし顔も整っているため
男性からの意見なうれしい
メンズからかっこいいって言われるのがね
なんかすごい同性からが嬉しいんですよ
スタイルが良くてイケメン千葉県が30代
ありがとうございます国立大学卒業の
インテリアだし顔はイケメンだと思う書く
じゃねえわ
[音楽]